[Music]  so  you are a dog  i am the batman  i'm not really great with animals yeah  i'm not really great with people  probably because of my traumatic  puppyhood as a child my family was taken  from me as a puppy i was taken from my  family so i steal myself my emotions  always in check no one ever getting past  my impenetrable defenses  [Music]  ah what the heck  that can't be sanitary  every day me and suits hang out  you literally worship the ground that  dude walks on technically he flies  batman works alone except for robin and  alfred commissioner gordon my eye t crew  whoever morgan freeman played what do i  have here oh squeezy bruce  squeezy what  that better be a licensed toy or i will  freak out